[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه والتي نبداها
بالعناوين
واشنطن اليوم
مع كبار قاده الجيش اهداف بلاده العسكريه
للعام المقبل
قلق اممي وادانه امريكيه من قرار حركه
طالبان منعه دراسه الفتيات في الجامعات
وزيره خارجيه استرا ليتصل العاصمه الصينيه
في مسعد لاصلاح العلاقات المتوتره بين
البلدين
اهلا بكم يستقبل الرئيس الامريكي
الابيض الذي اشار الى ان الرئيس الامريكي
سيعلن مساعده كبيره وجديده لاوكرانيا
ستشمل بحسب مسؤول امريكيين كبير نظام
باتريوت للدفاعات الجويه المتطوره وخلال
زيارته سيلقى الرئيس الاوكراني ايضا او
يلقي خطابا امام الكونغرس الامريكي
تتواصلوا المناورات الروسيه البلا الروسيه
المشتركه في اراضي بيلاروسيا وابهرت
مقاطعه مصوره نشرتها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اصطفاف عشرات الدبابات وقيام الجنود في
عمليات اقتحام ضد اهداف المشتركه بالذخيره
الحيه واستخدام اسلحه دقيقه مضاده
للدبابات
[موسيقى]
لقطات فيديو اخرى مصوره مشاهدينا اظهرت
لحظه قصه طائره مسيره اوكرانيه لهدف في
مقاطعه بريانس الروسيه على الحدود مع
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم الينا اللواء الركن محمد
محمود الثلجي المحلل العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا بك معنا سعاده اللواء اذا تاكيدات عن
تسليم اوكرانيا بعد زياره الرئيس بوتن
اليوم الى واشنطن انظمه الصواريخ عفوا الى
واشنطن سيتم تسليم اوكرانيا انظمه دفاع
باتريوت كيف يمكن ان يغير ذلك من اللعبه
على ارض المعركه
اه مرحبا بك سيدتي حقيقه انا يعني صواريخ
باترول هديه من الصواريخ التي تصنف بانها
صواريخ استراتيجيه وهي سلاح استراتيجي وهي
صواريخ يعني تمتاز بدقتها وتمتاز ايضا
بفاعليتها ولكن يعني هو الاعلان عن تزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه الصواريخ هو ربما يدفع
الصراع باتجاهات يعني مختلفه وربما يرقى
بهذا الشراع الى مستوى اكبر من المستوى
الذي نشهده حاليا وهذا هذا من شان ايضا
في في اللهجه في ما بين موسكو وما بين
ايضا واشنطن من من جهه اخرى وهذا يعني من
شان سيدتي ان يجدد الامان في رؤيه يعني
نهايه قريبه للحرب المتواصله 10 اشهر
وستدخل يعني ربما شهر الحادي عشر قريبا
هذا هذا من الناحيه ربما من الناحيه
السياسيه من الناحيه العسكريه سيكون له
طبعا يعني دخول هذا السلاح سيكون له طبعا
ايضا يعني
العديد من من
الامور التي يمكن ان تغير من استراتيجيه
العمليات او ما ان تغير من تكتيك العمليات
سواء عند الطرف الاوكراني والذي يؤكد بان
استخدام هذه الصواريخ سيكون استخداما
دفاعيا محضا وبدافع انسان وبرضرض همم يعني
كبح جماح الهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه وكذلك
هجمات الطائرات المسيره على على البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه وعلى المرافق الحيويه
التي من شانها ادامه شغل الحياه العامه في
اوكرانيا هذا من جاء ومن جهه اخرى ايضا هو
يعني حمايه للقواعد العسكريه وللقيادات
العسكريه ولانظمه القياده والسيطره حتى
تستطيع القوات العسكريه
العسكري في ذلك ذكرت ان انظمه الفاتوره
دفاعيه حتى اليس بها همم ثمانيه لانشرز
واربعه صواريخ في كلهم همم صواريخ بالستيه
ام لا
نعم هي سيدتي نعم هي ايام تحتوي على على
عده عده لانشرز هذه الصواريخ هي مجهزه بان
تكون او هذه المنظومات هي مجهزه للتصدي
للطائرات المقاتله وايضا هي ضد الطائرات
الاخرى وايضا يدود الصواريخ وخاصه
الصواريخ البالستيه
هل يحتاج الى تدريب وكم من الوقت من
التدريب يحتاج
للجيش الاكرانيا
هذا يعني فعاليه فعاليه هذه الصواريخ
ودخولها الى ساحه العمليات تعتمد على امور
عديده كم عدد المنظومات التي ستزود بها
الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا همم متى ستزود
يعني الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا بهذه
المنظمات هنالك حاجه للتدريب هذه
المنظومات هي منظومات معقده وتعمل بطواقم
وتعمل باطقم لها اجزاء متعدده منها وحدات
القياده والسيطره ووحدات الرادارات
والقادفات الرئيسيه وبالتالي يعني
الى تدريب وتدريب مستمر ولكن هنالك الكثير
من يعني من من ادعوا بان الولايات المتحده
كانت قد جهزت لهذا الامر مسبقا وانه يمكن
ان يكون قد تم تدريب اطقم عليها مسبقا
تحسبا لهذه لهذه
التسليم او تسليم هذه المنظومات الى الى
اوكرانيا ولكن هذه المعلومات غير مؤكده
لغايه هذه اللحظه
وهو ما ان سيتم تشغيل هذه المنظومات من
قبل الامريكيين نفسهم داخل الاوكرانيا ام
سيتم تدريب الجيش الاوكراني في المانيا
داخل قاعده عسكريه امريكيه
شديده المعلومات لا زالت لغايه الان بانه
سيتم تدريبهم في المانيا ولكن لا اتوقع
بان تدخل طواقم امريكيه بشكل واضح ربما
تدخل يعني بشكل غير واضح او بشكل سري
وتشغل هذه الطواقي ولكن هذا ينطوي على
مخاطره كبيره جدا هذا يعني وجود
عنصر بشري عسكري امريكي على الارض
الاوكرانيه يشغل معدات عسكريه تستهدف
القوات الروسيه هذا سيتم تفسيره بانه يعني
اشت مباشر وهذا ما اعلن عنه بي ان سبورت
مباشره بين الطرفين نعم بالتالي
عن ان هنالك مواجهه مباشره اذا دخل العنصر
البشري روسيا يعني قابلت بشكل او باخر ان
تدخل منظومه هذه المنظمات وقبلت بشكل او
باخر او او لم تستطع بمعنى اخر ايقاف المد
الكبير من هذا هذا التزويد بالاسلحه
والمعدات الى الى اوكرانيا وبالتالي
وبالتالي هي وقفت عاجزه على امام هذا
العام
روسيا بان ما ان تم تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه
باد باتريوت ستكون اهداف مشروعه لروسيا
سيدتي هي تشاهد كل انظمه الاسلحه التي
دخلت هي
سهدفت ايضا منظوماتس استهدفت مدافع
السيزرز استهدفت ايضا المدافع عن التربه 7
معظم المعدات التي دخلت اي معدات تدخل الى
اوكرانيا هي تصبح اهداف المشروعه للقوات
الروسيه وبالتالي هي قابله للاستهداف
وقاضي على الاستهداف
ربما كما ذكرت على التل وهي تختلف من حيث
قوتها ومن حيث قدرتها هل روسيا بالمقابل
عسكريا قادره على تحمل هذه المنظمات على
همم استهداف هذه المنظمات
جيد سيدتي اولا تعني لا اريد ان اقلل من
شان المنظومات ولكن هي منظومه الدفاع
الجوي محكمه ومنظومه الدفاع الجوي قادر
على التصدي للعديد من الاهداف كما ذكرت
ولكن هي تبقى منظومه الدفاع جوي هنالك
وسائل للتحايل على هذه المنظمات واظن بان
روسيا قد وصلت الى مستوى كبير جدا من
القدره على تفادي هذه المنظمات
الصاروخيه والطائرات المسيره التي
تستخدمها روسيا الان يعني اعطت روسيا
القدره على اشباح هذه المنظمات وهنالك ما
يسمى في مصطلح في الدفاع الجوي هو اشباع
منظومات الدفاع الجوي لارسال اهداف عديده
رخيصه الثمن
تطلق عليها هذه المنظمات عدد كبير من
الصواريخ وبالتالي يتم شباعها وتخرج هذه
المنظومات عن نوتي القتاليه وبالتالي يتم
ارسال اهداف صواريخ اخرى او طائرات مسيره
اخرى تستهدف الاماكن المراد الوصول اليها
وتدميرها وهذا هذا هذا الاسلوب متبع
واتبعته روسيا واذا لاحظت سيدتي بانها
كانت ترسل على سبيل المثال 40 او 50 طائره
مسيره تصل من هذه الطائرات 10 او 15 طائره
والباقي يتم تدبيره وهذا ما تريد روسيا
ويتعلم بان ليست جميع الصواريخ المرسله
وليست جميع الطائرات المرسله ستصل الى
الاهدافها يعني تقصد سعاده اللواء افهم من
كلامك ان روسيا تستنزف يعني اوكرانيا من
ناحيه المعدات العسكريه ربما سنتا ان نعرف
اكثر من اللقاء المرتقى ل- اا بوتن بعد
قليل مع القاده العسكريين لنقاش خطتهما
العسكريه لعام 20 23 شكرا لك من عمان
اللواء الركن محمد محمود التلجيه المحلل
العسكري والاستراتيجي
من المقرر المشاهدين ان يحدد الرئيس
الروسي من البوتن اليوم اهداف جيش بلاده
للعام 20 23 وذلك كما ذكرت خلال اجتماع مع
كبار القاده العسكريين وفقا لما اعلن عنه
الكرم للوافذ التجامن بالتزامن مع هذا
الاعلان حذر مسؤولنا عسكريون غربيون من
احتمال عوده التصعيد في الهجمات الروسيه
على اوكرانيا غير مستبعدين احتمال هجوم
على شمال اوكرانيا وتحديدا من الاراضي
البيلاروسيا حليفه بوتن الاولى في هذه
الحرب
حول ذلك تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كاتيا
طعم اهلا بك كاتيا ما المعلومات المتوفره
لدينا حول اجتماع بوت مع القاده العسكريين
مرحبا بك فاطمه بالفعل الساعه الساعات
اللاحقه سيعقد اجتماع للرئيس الروسيه وادي
ماركوتن مع قاده ااه الاقاليم القاده
العسكريين طبعا وعلى راسهم وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه
تقرير كامل عن عمل القوات الروسيه والصحه
التي تمت الوصول الى ايادي القوات الروسيه
خلال هذا العام وعلى هذا الاساس يتم وضع
ورسم خطط جديده لالعاب المقبل وبالتحديد
حول سير امل العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
همم اوكرانيا كان الرئيس الروسي طبعا
قبيله ذلك قد توجه الى روسيا وسط التقارير
كانت تحدثت عن امكانيات بدا او فتح حجمها
جديد لروسيا على اوكرانيا
حقيقه اولا الكرمنا النفع هذه التقارير او
عدم ااا يعني امكانيه روسيا فتح جبهه
جديده من الجانب الروس جانب البيلاروسي
عفوا لكن هي فقط تقوم بتدريبات دوريه
وتقوم بدعم الحدود الروسيه البيلاروسيا
الاوكرانيه ولكن لا يوجد كما قال لك رمان
جبهه جديده او لن يكون هناك هجوم من هذه
المنطقه وخبراء عسكريه ايضا تحدث عن عدم
امكانيه روسيا الان فتح جبهه جديده من
الشمال لربما هذه الخطا تكون فقط لدعم
القوات الروسيه في مكان تواجددها الان
وهمم بالاخص على المناطق التي تمت السيطره
عليها من قبل القوات الروسيه في لوغانسك
ايضا قد شاهدنا اجتماعا للرئيس الروسي مع
قاعده هذه المنطقه يوم امس بالاضافه الى
ذلك كان لقد تحدث عن ان الوضع هناك رئيس
روسي قال الوضع صعب جدا في هذه المناطق
همم اكد ده ضروره همم دعم القوات الامنيه
هناك همم طبعا همم التصدي لاي محاوله
اختراق لقوات الروسيه على الاراضي التي تم
ضمها من جديد ماذا عن انباء زياره زينسكي
الى واشنطن وتزويد واشنطن لاوكرانيا
بصواريخ من ردود فعل داخل موسكو
حقيقه فاطمه حتى الان لم يصدر اي تصريح من
الجانب الروسي حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن روسيا
كانت دائما تعتبر ان اي تزويد او اي سلاح
ستحصل عليه همم اوكرانيا من الغرب سواء
كان من واشنطن او الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون
هدفا مشروعا وكنا شهيد خلال الايام
السابقه القليله همم استهداف للقوات
الروسيه في في اوكرانيا استهداف لشحنات
كانت حصلت عليها اوكرانيا شحنات واا
الشحنات لاسلحه ومستودعات ايضا من جانب
الروسي بالاضافه لذلك كانت سقطت على
الاراضي الروسيه همم
طائرات مسيره انقذ اكثر
اوكراني كانت تحدث اجانب الروسي تعود
امريكيه تصنع لذلك روسيا تعتبر الاول انها
ستستهدف هذا هذه
الشحنات في حال همم
تعتبر انها الغرب يشارك بشكل مباشر من
خلال همم تزويدها الاسلحه يشار في هذه
المعركه المعركه ضد روسيا فاطمه شكرا لك
من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمه
التقى الرئيس الصيني شيجي بينج نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي الروسي ديميتري مدفديف
في بكين حيث عبر الرئيس الصيني خلال
اللقاء عن امله في حل الصراع في اوكرانيا
عبر الحوار السياسي كما اشار الى اهميته
تعميق العلاقات الثنائيه بين روسيا والصين
من جهته اكد مدفديف ان الحوار مع الرئيس
الصيني كان ايجابيا وبناءا
نشره هنا تستمر فيها بعد الفاصل الى
الموسكي عن منصب الرئيس التنفيذي لتويتر
بعد ايجاد بديل
احييكم من جديد الى الملف الافغاني والذي
اثار فيه قرار حكم الطالبان بمنع الفتيات
من ارتياد الجامعات قلقا عميقا وتمديدا
بالاوساط الدوليه الامين العام للامم
المتحده
قلقه العميق لقرار طالبان داعيا الى ضمان
المساواه في الحصول على التعليم على كل
المستويات وتزامنا قال البيت الابيض ان
الولايات المتحده على الاتصال بالحلفاء
حول قراري وزاره التعليم العالي الافغانيه
التي تديرها حركه طالبان وذكرت المتحدثه
باسم مجلس الامن القومي ادرين في بيان ان
الولايات المتحده تدين قرار طالبان الذي
لا يمكن الدفاع عنه بمنع الفتيات
الافغانيات من تلقي تعليم جامعي
نايل سيتي
مرارا وتكرارا ان شرعيه والدعم الذي تسعى
اليه الطالبان من المجتمع الدولي يبدا
بالشرعيه التي يكتسبونها من الشعب
الافغاني من خلال افعالهم
المتحده الخاصه لافغانستان
الدولي عبر اتخاذ قرارات لا تحظى بالشعبيه
حتى بين الافغان
يعني الحرمان من التعليم الثانوي انه في
غضون عامين لن تلتحق الفتيات بالجامعه هذا
القرار لا يحظى بشعبيه كبيره بين الافغان
وحتى داخل قياده طالبان لقد تم انتقاده من
قبل العالم الاسلامي باسره لقد قوض علاقه
الطالبان بالمجتمع الدولي
وسيتسبب في اضرار ستظل محسوسه لفتره طويله
في المستقبل
في الاستديو ينضم الينا الصحفيين
الافغانيين احمد السيد اهلا بك معنا سيد
احمد لماذا تتلاعب طالبان بملف تعليم
المراه يعني تاره يسمحون ويعني يقولون
بانهم مع تعليم المراه ويفتحون دراسه
الثانويه والمتوسطه وبعد بضع ساعات فقط
يغلقون المدارس الثانويه والان يقولون
بانهم يغلقون الجامعات امام الفتيات في
اخر يوم اختبار جامعي للفتيات يعني كنا
نتحدث انا وانت قبل الهواء وقلت لي ان
اليوم اخر يوم لدراسه الفتيات وهناك فتيات
يدرسنا لاربع سنوات وتم اغلاق الابواب
امامهن اليوم لمنعهم من التخرج
بموضوع همم تعليم المراه باعتقاله
شقه انه هناك انقسامات داخل طالبان بين
معارض ومؤيد المؤيد لقرار بينهم خمسه من
كبار الطالبان ومسؤوليه من ضمن رئيس
الوزراء ووزير التعليم العالي وحتى وزير
الحج والاوقاف وكذلك قاضي القضبان
القرار لكن المعارضين قد ظهر من بينهم
سراج الدين حقاني وكذلك هم لا يعقوب عرضوا
قرار زعيم طالبان منذ شهر كامل كانت كان
هذا القرار النهائي لكن عارضه ولكن لم
تفلح النتائج طالبا تتلاعب كذلك من جهه
اخرى قد يحتمل بانه قد تمارس ضغوط على
المجتمع الدولي ولكن هم باعتقادم بان هذه
تمارس بقوط الحصول على اعتراف الدوله من
همم المجتمع
الضغوط بمنع الفتيات وهم بالعكس يعني
يمنعون المجتمع الدولي من الاعتراف بهم
وتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه لهم
الامر تحدث في عدد من الاصوليين الاسلاميه
المتجددين سابقا في فرنسا
افغانستان تحدث بان هذا القرار غير
المنطقي وغير العقلاني حتى طالبان نفسها
لا تستطيع ان تبرر بانفسهم لم يستطيع ان
يبرروا هذا القرار غير المنطقي وغير
العقلاني
كذلك يعتقد من ناحيه اخرى من وزير التعليم
العالي في طالبان منذ تعيين منذ شهر ونصف
بدا بمجرد تعيينه بدا بالهجوم على جامعه
الفتيات وانها اماكن للانحلال والفساد
الاخلاقي وانه وجدوا وجدوا اشياء غير
اخلاقيه داخل هذه الاسكان الطالبات في
الجامعه
يعني سمعه التدريس والدراسه والسكن
الجامعي للفتيات على ان ربما ان يعني
يتعاطف معهم الشعب
انه يستطيع ان يمهد للشعب هذا القرار
وتعيين زعيم طالبان للمولى محمد نجيب
الوزير الجديد للتعليم العالي ياتي من هذا
الباب لانه من اشد المعارضين لتعليم
المراه وحتى في قبل اسبوعين اكثر همم
تهجم على الملك ظاهر شاء اخر ملوكه بانه
نشر الانحلال والفساد في افغانستان
وانه خالف التعليم الاسلاميه والعادات
الافغانيه بان اجبر همم الناس على ارسال
فتياتهم الى المدارس والجامعات
لذلك كانهم يعتقدون بهذا القرار وحتى
اليوم ااا كثير من قاده الطالبان وكثير من
الناشطين والمؤيدين للطالبان في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي اعرضوا هذا القرار بشكل
البارزين من طالبان في مواقع التواصل وحتى
بعض المسؤولين الصغار يعني في طالبان
اعرضوا هذا القرار
نرجع الى المبعوثه الامريكي السابق
قال بانه انا على عند ان عدد كبير من قاده
الطالبان معرضين للقرار اذا لا احد داخل
افغانستان يعرف كيف يتحكم خمسه او سته
اشخاص في المستقبل ملايين من الناس في
افغانستان
داخل القياده الافغانيه هناك ايضا معارضين
لهذا القرار والشعب الافغاني كذلك رغم
محاولات الت هو رخمه محاولات التسكيت
ومحاولات القمع واسكات المظاهرات الا ان
هناك الكثير الملايين يعرضون هذه القرارات
بنفسها فعلا بان هذا القرار يواجه الضغط
الدولي وكذلك وجه ضغط داخل من الشعب
الافغاني نجد اليوم في المدن الكبرى مثل
العاصمه كابول ومزار شريف هناك انتشار
امني كثير لقوات الامن التابعه لطالبان
ومنع الفتيات من من الوصول الى الميادين
العامه والحدائق خوفا من همم اندلاع
احتجاجات ومظاهرات وحتى اخر الفيديوهات
التي انتشرت تم فصل الكهرباء عن سكن
الطالبات في جامعه كابل وتم اخراج الفتيات
جبرا من همم
من الجامعه وكذلك في الوقت نفسه هناك شباب
الطلاب او من الجامع من جامعه كابل عارضوا
قرار اغلاق اعرضوا قرار منع الفتيات من
الجامع واكون بالرغم من النوم في اخر يوم
الامتحانات قادر وقاعات الامتحان اعتراضا
وحتى عدد من الاساتذه في عدد من الجامعات
اعلن معرضتهم للقرار وقدموا استقالتهم في
اليوم الاخير للامتحانات لنهايه السنه
الدراسيه
تعليم الحالي هو من يعارض ولكن هناك اثنين
او ثلاثه من وزاره التعليم السابقين تم
اقالتهم اجبارا لمعارضتهم لهذه القرارات
العامه السابق كان يحاول ان يضغط على قائد
الطالبان في الوسائل الاعلام بمحاوله ان
يعيد فتح المدارس الثانويه والمتوسطه امام
الفتيات
ولكنه زعيم طالبا يريد ان يغلق حتى مدارس
الابتدائيه للفتيات لذلك لم لم يتقبل ان
يكون الضغط من قبل همم وزير الملعب
بالتالي
يوافقه على هذه التصرفات
هذا كان في منتصف اكتوبر في منتصف نوفمبر
الشهر الماضي تم اقاله عبد الباقي حقاني
وزير التعليم العالي في طالبان الذي كان
عارض ان يصدر هو اي قرار لمنع الفتيات من
الجامعات وتم قالته وتعيين حاكم ولايه
كابل السابق ندى محمد نديم ولذلك هذه جميع
القرار هو من حصر في سته اشخاص يتراسهم
الملا هبه الله ومن بعده رئيس الوزراء حتى
ان الرئيس الوزراء والملا حسن او عفوا في
القرار الذي اصدره وزير التعليم العالي
يوم امس في
بخصوص التعليم المراه في الجامعات كان قد
اوعى ذا القرار بانه حسب قرار مجلس
الوزراء رقم كذا وكذا بتاريخ كذا
نامركم باغلاق جميع الجامعات الحكوميه
الخاصه والرفع والرفع بالتقرير بذلك لذلك
نجد انه حتى وزير العدل وقاضي القضاه عبد
الحكيم حقاني هو من اكثر المقربين لزعيم
طالبان هو كذلك ممن عارضوا هذا عرض او ممن
يؤيدون قرار منع الفتيات من الاردن نعم
يريدون القرار الوزير رئيس الوزراء ووزير
العدل والقاضي القضاه وحتى وزير الحج
والاوقاف وكذلك احد رئيس لك اكاديميه
العلوم الافغانيه كذلك يعتبر احد همم
علماء طالبان الكبار هم من الذين شددوا
على ذلك حتى ان الملا حسن اخون رئيس
الوزراء قال ما دمت حيا لا يمكن ان اصدر
قرار بعوده الفتيات المدارس المتوسطه
الثانويه
في افغانستان لكن ربما هذه الانقسامات في
الداخل بين القياده واصرار الشعب الافغاني
على التعليم الفتيات والمستقبل افضل
لابنائهم ربما سيؤدي الى نتائج في
المستقبل هذا طب شكرا لوجودك معنا في
الاستديو سيد احمد السيد الصحفي الافغاني
اسقط الكونجرس الامريكي من مشروع قانون
الانفاق الشامل البالغ مليار و700 مليون
دولار اسقط بندا كان من شانه ان يؤمن
الاقامه الشرعيه للاجئين الافغان داخل
الولايات المتحده وفق تقارير اعلاميه قرار
الكونغرس مشاهدينا اضعف امل الكثيرين من
المهاجرين الافغان بامكانيات حصولهم على
الاقامه الدائمه في الولايات المتحده بعد
انهاء القوات الامريكيه مهامها في
افغانستان في اغسطس لعام 20 21
نبقى في افغانستان حيث تدشن الامم المتحده
الف منزل لضحايا الزلزال في منطقه برمل
بمقاطعه بكتيكا شرقا البلاد والتي ضربها
زلزال عنيف في 22 من شهر يونيو الماضي
المشروع تم تقديم الدعم فيه من مجموعه من
البلدان المالحه بما فيها الصندوق
السعوديه للتنميه نتابع
بعد قرابه
الاشخاص فيهم
ودمرت حوالي ثلاثه الاف منزل تسلم الامم
المتحده الف منزل مشيد للمتضررين في منطقه
برنل النائيه
كما خططنا لانشاء مدرستين لدى اطلاله فصل
الربيع في هذه القريه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
تقول ان المنازل الجديده
وبوابات
شمسيه تستوعب ثمانيه الاف شخص للعيش فيها
زمونه
الى قلوب المواطنين
نحن اليوم نشارك معهم فرحتهم التي لا توصف
ورغم تعهداتي منظمات الاغاثه يزعم بعض
سكان المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال انهم
يعيشون في خيام وحفر رطبه حفروها لانفسهم
ولم يتم تقديم الدعم الاوائي والغذائي
الكافي لهم
كما لم نتخذ اي اجراءات وليس لدينا معدات
للتدفئه نطالب جهات المعنيه بدعمنا ووعدت
مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
ببناء المزيد من المنازل العام المقبل
الذي يفصلنا عنه اسبوعان فقط وسيتم
توزيعها على ضحايا الزلزال في كل من منطقه
سبيره في خوست وديان في باكتيكا شرقي
افغانستان
يواجهه اهالي المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
الكثير من المشاكل فالمناطق جبليه والطقس
شديد البروده يضيف معظمهم ان الطقس
البارده قد يت هو في اضرار اكثر من
الزلزال في وقت قد تتفشى بينهم الامراض
الموسميه وخاصه لدى النساء والاطفال عبد
الله نادر العربيه كابول
تقوم بزياره الى الصين لاجراء محادثات
تهدف لاصلاح انقطاع طويل في العلاقات
رفيعه المستوى بين استراليا والصين تسبب
بفرض عقوبات تجاريه ووقوع احتكاكات سياسيه
من المقرر ان تلتقي نظيرها الصيني اليوم
في اول زياره على هذا المستوى منذ اربع
سنوات وتامل استراليا في انهاء الحظر الذي
تفرضه الصين على والدتها وتحرير مواطنين
استراليين محتجزين في بكين
قالت كوريا الشماليه ان العقوبات الاضافيه
لن توقف برنامج الصاروخي بعد ايام من
اطلاقها صاروخين بالستين متوسطي المدى وفق
ما ذكرته وكاله رويترز للانباء المزيد في
التقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
كوريا الشماليه تحد واضح وصارخ لاي نداءات
بوقف برامجها الصاروخيه وبينما تندد دول
الغرب بصواريخ كوريا الشماليه
فالاخيره مستمره في مساعدها
[تصفيق]
بعد ايامنا من اطلاق كوريا الشماليه
صاروخين بالستين متوسطين المدى فيما وصفته
بانه اختبار مهم لتطوير القمر صناعي
للتجسس هي الاحدث في عام شهيده سلسله من
الاختبارات الصاروخيه منها عبر للقارات في
انتهاك للعديد من قرارات مجلس الامن
الدوليه
الامريكيا وصفت تجربه صاروخيه بالتهديد
للمنطقه
معتقد ان تجارب كوريا الشماليه الصاروخيه
تشكل تهديدا للمنطقه والمجتمع الدولي
ونؤكد ان التزامنا بالدفاع عن كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان صارم
[تصفيق]
واسطه التفاخر الكوري الشمالي بمنظومه
اقمارها الصناعيه الا ان خبراء اجانب
شككوا في ان تلك الانظمه التي اختبرتها
كوريا الشماليه قادره على العمل بشكل
طبيعي
من كوريا
التي استنكرت تلك التصريحات واكدت في رد
المضاد ابتسم بالتهديد المبطن ان المشككين
في قدرات صواريخ كوريا الشماليه سيعلمون
قريبا ما يمكن ان تفعله تلك الصواريخ
مشيره الى ان بلادها لا تخشى العقوبات ولن
يوقف ذلك
[تصفيق]
في المقابل تحركات الامريكيه كوريه جنوبيه
من جهه جددت واشنطن عرضها للجوء الى
الوسائل الدبلوماسيه لحل الخلافات وهو عرض
لطالما رفضته كوريا الشماليه
ومن جهه اخرى تدريبات مشتركه ل واشنطن مع
سول شملت نشره قذيفه ومقاتلات وفقما افادت
وكاله رويترز نقلا عن وكاله نيوز 1
روان حمزه العربيه
افادت احدى اكبر الشركات التي انضمت الى
استحواذ ايلون ماسك لتويتر بقيمه 44 مليار
دولار بانها تتوقعوا تحقيق ما يصل الى
خمسه اضعاف اموالها في غضون سنوات قليله
وذلك على الرغم من المشاكل التي تمر بها
شركه التواصل الاجتماعي والقرويه تعز
وبحسب شركه
ومقرها ميامي فقد استثمرت بقيمه 360 مليون
دولار الى جانب ماسك في صفقه شراء تويتر
وتعتقد ان ماسك سيستفيد من 229 مليون
مستخدم نشاط يوميا على تويتر كانوا
تاريخيا اقل من حيث الدخل
تحركات الملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك
للتخلي عن رئاسه مجلس اداره الشركه وفقاء
اكسيوس تثير انقسام تويتر
اكثر من 57% مؤيدا لاستقاله الماسك انقسام
المستخدمين للمنصه قابله انقسام اخر فماسك
لا يمسك وحده بكل مفاصل منصه بل هناك
مستثمرون اخرون قلت او كثره نسبتهم وهؤلاء
منقسمون ايضا حول تحركات الهم ماسك للتخلي
عن رئاسه مجلس الاداره ووافق اكسيوس مشينا
الى ان اعلان ماسك التخلي عن مجلس الاداره
مرتبط بوجود بديل والبديل انه وجد بطبيعه
الحال ستكون تبعيته لمصر وذلك ما يعدد
فرضيه ان يتخلي يا ماسك عن مجلس الاداره
لن يغير الشيء باعتباره المالك ما يشير
الى ان التغيير قد يكون صورا وليس جوهريا
المساهمون البعض منهم يعتقد ان ماسك قد
فعل الى حد كبير ما قال انه سيفعله تقليل
التكاليف وزياده المشاركه الم قصير المدى
لتحقيق مكاسب طويله المدى يقول متفائل
بالمقابل يخشى اخرون من خسائر كبيره جراء
ما يحدث من اجراءات على المنصه خاصه بعد
ان توقفت اعلانات وغادر موظفون
هدى تقف شبكه التواصل الاجتماعيه هذه بين
جناحيه سياسات يراها البعض غريبه ويراها
الاخر مقبوله بعض الشيء سياسه حولت هذا
المكان الى ساحه هي والهدوء والاستقرار
الى خصام في خضم خوف على مستقبل غامض يحيط
بالمكان ومن فيه عصام عبد السلام العربيه
[موسيقى]
اكدت عائله مدير الاستخبارات الليبيه
السابق عبد الله السنوسي انها طلقات
اخبارا من مقر اعتقاله في قاعده معتيقه
بانه جارات تسليمه للولايات المتحده واكدت
عائله السنوسي ايضا ان تسليمه جاء بطلب من
واشنطن ووافقت عليه حكومه الدبابه على
غرار تسليم ابو عجه لموسى المتورط في قضيه
واشارت عائله السنوسي الى انها لم تتمكن
من التواصل معه في الفتره الماضيه وان
اعلان تسليمه لواشنطن بشكل رسمي مساله وقت
وكانت قبائل اباري التي ينتمي اليها
السنوسي طالب في وقت سابق هذا الاسبوع
بالافراج عنه خاصه بعد اسقاط حكم الاعدام
الذي صدر ضده في عام 2015 وهددت بوقف
العمل في حقول النفط في
الجنوبتنا تستمر فيها بعد الفاصل
السلطات الصحيه الاوروبيه ترصد اكبر
انتشارا لانفلونزا الطيور في تاريخ القاره
اليوم
انظمه باتريوت
الرئيس الروسي يحدد اليوم مع كبار قاده
الجيش اهداف بلاده العسكريه للعام المقبل
قلق اممي وادانه امريكيه من قرار حركه
طالبان دراسه الفتيات في الجامعات
وزيره خارجيه استراليا تصل العاصمه
الصينيه في مسعا لاصلاح العلاقات المتوتره
بين البلدين
حياكم الله من جديد خطوات عده مشاهدينا
اتخذتها السعوديه في السنوات الاخيره لجذب
الاستثمارات الى القطاع السياحي من ابرزها
اطلاق مشاريع عملاقه وتغيرات جذريه في
نظام التاشيرات والنتيجه هي فرص استثماريه
في القطاع تقدرها ساندر اند بورد نصف
تريليون دولار التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
نتابع
[موسيقى]
ابتداء من العام الجديد ستبدا المشاريع
العملاقه في السعوديه مثل الجديه والبحر
الاحمر بترحي اول منتجاتها السياحيه في
خطوه لا تهم السائحين فحسب بل المستثمرين
ايضا اثناء القمه العالميه للمجلس العالمي
للسفر والسياحه والتي عقدت في الرياض في
نوفمبر الماضي اتضحت الصوره الجديده
للسعوديه في اذان المستثمرين في القطاع
السياحي
[موسيقى]
القمه العالميه للسياحه وسط تسجيل اكثر من
ثمانيه الاف مشارك من بينهم 250 رئيسا
تنفيذيا لكوبرا شركات السفر والضيافه
عالميا جوليا سمسم رئيسه مجلس العالم
للسفر والسياحه لا خاصه ما يحدث في
السعوديه قائله انما يحدث من تحول في
السعوديه هو ثمره استثمارات بلغت 800
مليار دولار والذي يعتبر اضخم استثمارا في
تاريخ السفر والسياحه هذه الاستثمارات
الحكوميه التي تنظمها الاستراتيجيات
الوطنيه للسياحه والتي اطلقت عام 2019 هي
مشجع اساسي لتدفقات رؤوس اموال القطاع
الخاص ولكن استثمارات الحكومه وحدها تكفي
وهنا تبرز اهميه الخطوات التشريعيه
والتنظيميه التي اتخذتها السعوديه لتحفيز
القطاع السياحي ومنها التغيير شامل في
نظام التاشيرات السياحيه
قطاع السياحه احد القطاعات الاكثر استفاده
من رؤيه المملكه 20 30 حيث تقدر الوكاله
الفراسه لاستثماريه التي يولدها القطاع
السياحي بين مشاريع وبنيه تحتيه وغيرها
باكثر من 500 مليار دولار
وفرت هذه الفرص الاستثماريه حتى ما التوفر
منصه واحده امام المستثمرين من القطاع
الخاص وهو الدور الذي يلعبه صندوق التنميه
السياحي منذ اطلاقه في يونيو الماضي والذي
يعمل على استقطاب برؤوس الاموال الى
القطاع الذي سيضيف عشره في المئه للاقتصاد
السعودي بحلول العام 2030 سعره حمدان
العربيه
السلطات الصحيه الاوروبيه قالت ان اوروبا
استحودت على اكبر انتشارا لانفلونزا
الطيور في القاره العام الماضي في ما يدرس
الخبراء جدوى اللقاحات وقالت هيئه
الاوروبيه لسلامه الاغذيه والمركز
الاوروبي للوقايه من الامراض ومكافحتها
انه بين اكتوبر العامه الماضي سبتمبر
الماضي تم اكتشاف حوالي 2500 حاله
الانفلونزا الطيور في مزارع 37 دوله
اوروبيه في حين ذبح حوالي 50 مليون طائر
في المزارع المتضرره
ننتقل مباشره معكم الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع
الزميل ناصر
لارقام جلسه تداولات هذا اليوم السوق
السعوديه على استقرار كانت مرتفعه بعض
الشيء وشاهدنا المؤشر فوق العشره الاف
وثلثمائه لكن عادت لتفقد هذه المكاسب التي
هي كانت بين بالاصل المكاسب طفيفه في
بدايه جلسه هذا اليوم هذه الاسهم الاكثر
تداولا حاليا الراجحي والسهم الاكثر نشاطا
تراجع بسبعه اشهر كابلات الرياض طبعا في
ثالث جلسه تداول لها اول جلسه خفض السهم ب
12% ثاني جلسه شهدنا بعض الارتفاعات عادت
اليوم لترتفع لكن ما يزال كابلات الرياض
دون مستويات ال43 ريالا وهو سعر الاكتتاب
عند الطرح اما بالنسبه للاسهم التي
نراقبها فهدين المصريين زادا من توزيعات
النقديه عن النصف الثاني مقارنه من النصف
الثاني من العام الماضي العربي على بعض
التراجع لكن الانما ما زال محافظا على
مكاسب اليوم باكثر من واحد في المئه اما
بالنسبه باقي الاسهم البنكيه فهذه نظره
عليها الاهلي مرتفع باكثر من واحد في
المئه انتقالا الى الاسهم الاكثر نشاطا في
سوق دبي اعمار هو السهم الاكثر نشاطا عند
الخمس دراهم 95 فلس دي واليوم متراجعه ب
1:15 النقطه المئويه وهي تتداول اليوم
x بدون احقيه التوزيعات هناك بعض الضغوط
على دبي الاسلامي وايضا على الامارات دبي
الوطني التي تضغط على المؤشر سهم تبريد
متراجع اليوم باربعه في المئه بعد مكاسب ب
10% في جلسه البارحه في ضوء افصاح اليوم
همم بعد الاخبار الصحفيه البارحه عن ان
تبريد الاماراتيه زادت استثمارها في تبريد
السعوديه اشترت 55 او اسهم اضافيه بقيمه
55 مليون ريال من مساهم اخر في تبريد
السعوديه وهي شركه مطلق الصناعيه الان
اصبحت حصتها 21% في تبريد السعوديه وذلك
بعد قيام صندوق الاستثمارات العامه بدوره
لا حصه في تبريد السعوديه من خلال طرح خاص
لتصبح حصه الصندوق 30% في تبريد السعوديه
في الاسهم الاكثر نشاطا في ابو ظبي ها هي
لائحه الاسهم الاكثر نشاطا موت بلاي على
تراجع بواحد في المئه واخيرا في السوق
الكويتيه وبعد تراجعات واسعه النطاق على
الاسهم الكويتيه الرئيسيه بالامس كنا قد
شاهدنا مؤشر الكويت الاول ينخفض بواحد في
المئه في جلسه البارحه اليوم بعض
الاستقرار على المؤشر بيتك لا تزال على
تراجع بثلاث ارباع النقطه المئويه وكذلك
جيليتي ولكن بعض الارتفاعات التي نشهدها
على الاسهم المصرفيه في السوق الكويتيه
اخيرا ما زالنا نبقي اعيننا على حركه
اسعار النفطه التي شهدت في الاشهر القليله
الاخيره تراجعات قويه جدا تحديدا في
الشهرين الماضيين لكن اسعار النفط لا تزال
مستقره وتتراوح حول عتبه الثمانين دولار
بالنسبه للبراند وحاول عتبه 76$ بالنسبه
اخيرا اشاره هنا الى ان اسعار الذهب كانت
قد قفزت البارحه الى ما فوق الالف 1800$
للانثى لتكون تمتحن من جديد اعلى مستويات
لسعر الذهب في سته اشهر هذه كانت مشاهدينا
وقفتنا مع الاسواق الان من جديد نعود الى
استديوهاتنا في الرياض لنكمل النشره ماء
زميلتي فقط
لمحاربه الاميه بين اطفال النازحين ويدرس
في المدرسه نحو 600 طفل حرمتهم الظروف من
فرص التعليم بسبب النزوح
بعد سنوات من حرماله من التعليم الاساسي
تجهز بطوله محمد النازحه التي تعيش في
مخيم خارج القدس وابنها نوح للحاق بمدرسه
تقدم التعليم الاساسي لاطفال النازعي هذا
المخيم بخطوات سريعه ينضم نوح عبد القادر
ذو تسع سنوات الى مئات من اطفالها هذا
المخيم الذين يبداون صباحهم المدرسيه
بوجبه فطور قد تعينهم على الجلوس لساعه
على مقاعد الدراسه ولمدرسه عباره عن خمس
غرف يجلس فيها نحو 600 تلميذ يدرسون
المواد الاساسيه في الفتره الصناعيه
والمسائيه وتقول النظيفه حسينا صاحبه
مبادره والعامله في مجال دعم النازحين ان
هذه الخطوه تاتي في اطار جهودها لدعم
النازحين حيث يعيشوا الاف الاطفال من
المشردين بدون تعليمه
قرانيه ثم انشات هذه المدرسه لدعم اطفال
النازحين الذين يعانون من الاميه ادعوا
جميع القادرين الى دعمها هؤلاء الصغار
لبناء مستقبلهم
ويعملوا في المدرسه اثنا عشر مدرسا متطوعا
يدرسون المواد الاساسيه اعتمادا على منهج
وزاره التعليم صوماليه
[موسيقى]
وادعو كل من يستطيع ان يساعده هؤلاء
الصغار الذين يندمجون في المجتمع ووصلوا
الى مستويات عاليه من التعليم الاساسي
وقال لي وانا في البيت وكنت العب فقط وتم
الحاق بهذه المدرسه وانا سعيدنا الان لاني
استطيع ان اكتب وان اقرا
هذه السيده ونتمنى ان تتحسن احوالنا بشكل
عام ونجد مساعدات دائما
على هذه المبادره التي اتت بنتائج مشجعه
على نشر هذه الفكره وايصالها الى المخيمات
المجاوره عبد الرحمن بخيره العربيه
استقبل الجمهور المغربي منتخب بلاده
استقبال الابطال بعدما قدمه من اداء في
مونديال قطر وتحقيق المركز الرابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ويا الله
عالميه
هبربوا القاع اللي من عاديه لعقيله ويلا
ويلي الرجراجي ناري ناري ونحو زياش ودراري
يا زينب بلادي وهذا شلون سجل عليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى الاحتفالات في قلب العاصمه
الارجنتينيه
[موسيقى]
اما في ماليزيا فقد اسفلت فيضانات عاريمه
ضربت الساحل الشرقي لشبه الجزيره عن تشريد
الالاف من ديارهم في مغامرات المياه
المباني والطرقات
[موسيقى]
قبل الختام وقفه مع ابرز الصور
لشهر فبراير لهذا العام متابعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
واشنطن اليوم
رئيس الروسي يحدد اليوم مع كبار قاده
الجيش اهداف بلاده العسكريه للعام المقبل
قلق اممي وادانه امريكي من قرار حركه
طالبان منع دراسه الفتيات في الجامعات
ووزيره خارجيه استراليا تصل العاصمه
الصينيه في مسعا لاصلاح العلاقات المتوتره
بين البلدين
في امان الله
[موسيقى]